What are the Council configurations?
To make decisions
in different policy areas,
the Council meets
in specialised meetings
known as Council configurations.
Each configuration
is made up of ministers
from the member states.
It is the ministers who vote
on behalf of their national government.
Each configuration
deals with specific issues.
For example,
economic and finance ministers
meet to discuss financial affairs,
and ministers of justice
discuss justice issues.
In total the Council of the EU meets
in 10 different configurations.
There is no hierarchy
among Council configurations.
However,
the General Affairs Council
and the Foreign Affairs Council
have specific roles
defined in the EU treaties.
Meetings of each configuration
take place regularly.
Some meet every month,
some 3-4 times a year,
and some on an ad-hoc basis.
Over a 150 preparatory bodies
prepare the ground for the meetings.
Meetings are chaired by the minister
from the member state
holding the Council presidency;
with the exception of
the Foreign Affairs Council,
which is chaired by
the High Representative
of the Union for Foreign
Affairs and Security Policy.
At their meetings,
ministers work together
to find common solutions
on issues of shared interest.
The Council takes decisions
using simple majority,
qualified majority or unanimity voting.
When discussing or voting
on a legislative proposal,
Council meetings are public.
Meetings are also public
when the Council is debating major issues
affecting the interests of the EU
and its citizens.
Find out all you want to know
about Council configurations and much more
on Consilium.europa.eu